we're live are we really live we are
live we are live guys okay episode 91
with zenner adam and gerard
uh with a lot to cover man we were
actually listening to a song pope pimp
and uh do or die and then you ask me
what the other song was i was listening
to last time with phil and sheree and
mario
is uh uh maya best of me
but the second version part two not part
one with i think she's got one with
jadakiss we were listening to well
that's your claim to fame you don't like
the main song you like the like their
second best side what's that side b
b-side
boy oh boy there's gerard oh boy oh boy
get out gerard i'm touching it off early
call it like i see it and maya happened
maya aaliyah how'd you see it all the
good times huh how'd you see it if she
was
was she walking away from you
i'm 99 hot 97 summer jam 99 had met at
the old giant stadium
yeah man you know she's still doing
stuff she's just low-key maya yeah is
that right yeah she's still doing and
but she still looks good
yeah she still looks good you know it's
but you gotta that was a long time ago
though kira that was a great time yeah
that was that was i mean that was the
mtv that was the halcyon days of mtb i
kind of see you as a vh1 guy i don't
know why i did i liked uh i liked the
one with the bubble pop-up video i was a
big pop-up video guy really learn and
listen at the same time were you a vh1
guy or no you're jukebox like 69 boys
that's you american bands take what your
mama gave you right
now no question about it miami miami is
you oh you no matter you have a striking
resemblance to uncle luke as it turns
out yeah uncle uncle jew
okay so so we got a lot of crazy topics
to go with we're going to get a caller
from australia i think we're going to
call them probably early to see what's
really going on in australia with that
video from guardian that was posted i
don't know you saw that girl getting
choked by the cop she kicks the other
girl though
i'm excited to see it kai do we have not
the good kind of excitement yeah i mean
it's it's pretty intense what happens
there so we'll call somebody from
australia and keep throwing around the
term new world order like like very very
loosely just keep throwing it out there
did you see what michael bury's been
saying lately or no have you been
following anything like have you been
following
which company he's bought the most puts
on and which companies he's bought the
most called from the big show call
options and they're saying big short
two's coming up we're going to talk
about which
call options he's got and which put
options he's got put when you buy put
you're assuming that stock's going up
call is going up i'll give you the
different companies kai can you pull up
uh michael bury's article from today
business insider today he's got some
bold
predictions coming up based on three
different indicators we'll talk about
that
uh new york city did you guys see new
york city video the governor yesterday
what she did oh yeah yeah the national
guard firing all the
unvaccinated cuomo's been out for how
long now has it been a month six weeks
he's gone and what's the new lady's name
kathy cathy just just kathy
i don't know her last name but cathy but
whatever she's doing she's a catholic
establishment i'm like yeah actually
actually
oh what's he about to do wait what's he
about to do you got a text from her wait
no he's licensed it's not my governor
ronnie d get out of here ronnie d get
out of here
let's see it yeah all right everybody
this is
just kidding
i'm not a jerk i'm not even just doxxed
me i'm not i'm not even gonna i'm not
even being facetious he looks like a
mass murderer
[Laughter]
agree holy moly yes that that's not the
angry mug shot
there's an actual reason behind this
guys the the old wives tale is to look
as bad as you can possibly look when you
get your your driver's license taken so
god forbid you get pulled over they're
like oh no he hasn't been drinking this
that's what he looks like all the time
question for you how old is he
desantis is 44.
wow i think a little older i'm going to
say
i'm going to say 51
just keep it in his perspective yeah
you're never wrong
okay he's 51. do you know the age or no
okay don't look how old is the santas
desantis uh 55 55. you said 40 44.
september 14th 1978. the guy's 43 years
old
never wrong he's never been here just
turned 43 yeah
last week 10 days right happy birthday
happy belated birthday to the santas he
just turned 43 libra season yeah i mean
it's not he's not it just shows you how
politics ages he looks like he looks
like a virgo though he talks like a
virgo he talks like everything's you
know perfectionist like a virgo what's
what's a libra what does a libra look at
his balance trying to figure things out
they're kind of you know see both sides
of the argument their mediators their
you know libras are you know very
different wiring they have hey let's get
into the title scientifically proven
proven the greatest sign in the world is
a libra
this is proven there's no question about
the birthdays of
uh september 23rd probably until october
27th my mom's a libra you're a libra and
isn't dylan a libra dylan's that's what
i wanted that's interesting dylan's
birthday how was it dylan's a libra
dylan just turned eight years old silly
boy so proud of that guy youngster good
kid man
eight years old and he's 795 pounds
his trainer of still heat i mean if
he'll eat this
for olympia the way he's going but uh
daddy what's a deadlift
dilly's gonna be about six five six six
dollars
dylan's a big boy with swagger charm and
a sweetheart very interesting
combination
very very weird comment and very nice
gift you send them yes of course
everybody send gifts everybody had a
gift wrap mario's just brings a gift a
toy not rap and
adam
always wants to save money he saves that
money he sends a video of will ferrell
let the boy watch and i wanted him to
watch i want him to learn earlier and
you saw the video i really wanted him to
learn like his father learned before him
and his father
gabriel gabriel
okay by the way facebook and instagram
threatened with ban from iphone after
secret slave market uncovered on apps do
you realize apple banning facebook and
instagram it's a little
intense right there for that to be
taking place i thought facebook and
instagram are uncancelable imagine if
apple does that to him amazon is
lobbying the us government to make pot
legal
tom brady is the nfl's most disliked
player in the most in most of the nation
studies shows and zener says uh
that uh uh brady carried belichick that
bro belichick may not even be in the top
three greatest coaches of all time he
said he might not be in top 100 no i
never said that i said he probably is in
the top hundred he probably he is not
he's not proven that to me yet let's
let's look at the body of work when he's
done with his body
the fact that he's 10 games under 500
without tom brady means nothing to you
name five better coaches than bill
belichick okay uh sean payton andy
by the way you didn't even say lombardi
like lombardi's not better than no but
lombardy i don't i don't go back that
far i i prefer to stay more johnson and
sean payton though yeah those guys you
know what it's easy to just say that and
laugh at me but let's see what he's done
without tom brady when it's all up let
me ask you a different question yeah you
got two choices parcels or belichick
would you choose uh i would probably
pick parcells i would pick parcells for
his ability
brady was still on that team his
presence was still alive on that roster
okay that was his one winning season
without him
look at his record
did you see what he's done so far this
year and last year there's two arguments
here there's two and you know our
audience loves sports
one of the arguments is the following
one of the arguments is if belichick
standalone argument won the greatest
coaches of all time if not the greatest
but the second argument is who carried
who brady belichick
the argument of brady belichick right
now it's not even close it's obviously
going to brady he's proven the last two
years as of right now because no way man
by the way isn't belichick right now one
and two they're one and two mac jones
said uh he threw for two or three
interceptions quarterback he's starting
over all these excuses always alice
excuse me wait wait but go back to it
you're taking belichick over brady yes
absolutely oh my god here let me ask you
a question if belichick is so smart why
did he get rid of tom brady why did that
job to drew freaking henson man
if tom brady is a six round draft pick
of the new york jets he's he's uh he's
you guys belichick didn't play
football you're both overreaching this
an act to get a plug for vt sports be
honest
you know he's listening because he's a
big entrepreneur the angriest guy
listening to this going yeah you're
right gerard is drew freaking bledsoe
because if marvin lewis doesn't blow his
spleen up drew bledsoe's got three uh
super bowl rings and he's the king of
boston
you guys are acting like i said um les
steckel is the greatest nfl coach of all
time i'm simply saying belichick hasn't
done squat without tom brady nothing
no he didn't he was an assistant coach
he was the defensive coordinator he
didn't win him he was part of a staff
that won a super bowl tom i don't know
what happened with you and and bill
belichick everything we'll work it out
don't worry everything's gonna be okay
folks if you're listening to this by the
way for the for the 20 of you guys that
follow sports here's a question for you
thumbs up if you have a choice
you can pick belichick to build around a
team or brady to pick around a team if
brady's your choice smash thumbs up if
it's belichick you want to build around
a team around a coach put thumbs down
i'm curious to see what happens right
now we got 112.
i'd be curious you know what people say
yeah but i know we make this joke a lot
that our audience doesn't we're useful
for you though but our audience you
genuinely think our audience doesn't
even like sports a little bit no they 20
that's why i said 20 percent i got to
say more than that maybe 22 maybe 22
would have been increasing but this is a
business plus mine too like okay who
would you build a business around would
you build a business around a great ceo
or your top performer like what's who if
you haven't first of all
i asked this question from uh uh i asked
this question from uh who's the great
player of new york uh uh old school
anyways he's uh
i cannot forget no in new york city he
played for nick's back in the day seven
years ago
no one at that era though he played with
phil jackson
yes and i said what's the most important
thing to build around is it ownership
i've asked this question a few times
from owners players all these guys
ownership a rockstar player a head coach
a gm who's the most super star get me a
superstar guess what he said he said
ownership is number one no doubt he said
ownership is number one
then superstar
then head coach then gm yeah it was so
interesting the way he put it he says
because if like imagine if donald
sterling has michael jordan you think
the clippers are going to go be the next
chicago bulls hell no no no it's not
going to do nothing like that right so
you need an owner at the top like a
craft you know you people don't give
enough credibility to guys like
steinberg or like jerry buss 33 years of
owning the lakers the guy won 10
championships one out of three years the
lakers won it so
that's the argument but superstar after
you have a great owner listen your
bradys don't come along all the time
yeah but you gotta hold your breath they
don't get hurt it's not even close all
right listen
in the entertainment industry
specifically you can have an
unbelievable writer incredible cast all
right but if the director doesn't know
what he's doing the executive producer
doesn't know how to promote the film or
doesn't that the movie's gonna be
terrible how many times have you seen an
amazing look at batman with val kilmer
george clooney incredible actors massive
cast all the money in the world thrown
at this thing and then you get you know
bad suits with nipples you know what i'm
saying like that's some people like that
the joel schumacher batman nobody in the
world is going to say val kilmer is a
bad actor right val kilmer is a massive
incredible actor doc great security
guard though
he's crazy no no no that's a londran
right
i mean so you got doc holliday and you
got you know one of the great character
actors of all time he becomes batman
it's a terrible movie it's always it's
top down guys you could the the best
leadership guys can create an
environment for people to be successful
people to perform that's that's what i
think i think look you could be an
unbelievable salesman but if they if you
can't have a team around you that's
going to be able to support by the way
it's not even close 90 of people said
they would choose brady over belgium
they would choose
brady over belichick yeah what yeah as a
player
yeah i don't i don't think bill
belichick should be lining up across
tom brady let's see what happens let's
see what happens by the way what about
that kick this week 66 yards 66 insane
you notice how we have we haven't seen
paula scarcely all week he's a huge
lions fan he's like on suicide walks
right now
that's a painful race
[Music]
that's a painful yeah
from your own side by the way can you
call that the greatest field goal
winnings you know regular season
you know all the time maybe regular i'm
not going to put a playoffs but i'm
going to say regular scenes i think so
for sure shout out to your new creative
director fellow ut alum with uh zp zp is
a ut hook them horizontal who is vp by
the way who is who is zp that's by the
way that's our new line with zp
oh zp yesterday we're having lunch at uh
where were we at at uh gary's farmhouse
with zp with mario
and i uh come and i joined them with sam
with us as well sam was with us as well
and mari's like you know we're having a
romantic moment here right now i'm like
what are you guys talking about they
were talking about some show
and then that conversation went to
talking about the fact that just three
months ago i'm on a flight and i'm like
you know i haven't seen basic instinct
for 30 years i put in basic instinct
kids are sitting next i forgot how bad
it was yeah yeah no joke kids by the way
fantastic movie yeah yeah fantastic
great story forget about all the you
know the the the
you know stretching yourself you can't
forget about it but i'm talking about
like the movie by itself great movie
richard
came on
michael uh michael douglas michael
douglas i get those two confused
best was richard or was uh michael
douglas's partner who you know kind of
the heavy guy who's part every line was
a cliche in that movie joe esther house
wrote that thing and uh smoking stuck
with cigarettes over here so ridiculous
do you remember the first time you saw
basic instinct uh probably when it came
out 1992.
how great was newman in that scene by
the way i like see
yeah yeah somehow you got michael
douglas yeah you got noob sweating
bullets yeah so you let the boy watch
dylan i don't think he's ready for basic
instinct yet because it may uh uh fire
him up a little too much but i think we
talk about sliver afterwards with uh i
don't know if you remember
baldwin yeah yeah yeah which baldwin
there's like 12 of them i don't know
billy wanted it yeah billy baldwin i
know it wasn't alec
name a song the main song from sliver we
figured it out name the main song from
sliver
i'm gonna say she drives me crazy by the
fine young cannibals okay that's a good
try
i like that's a good try it was a slow
smooth sexy song i remember that
wise men saying these words yeah
yeah but it was a ub40 style the ub40
version yes yeah great so i remember
that of course
so listen if you're watching this in a
couple years all right and and you did
get a chance to watch basic instinct
it's not the 70s anymore things are a
little better
the 90s work great for movies don't be
afraid
i don't disagree i think so 90s had
like romantic comedies and just just
yeah they weren't trying to have an
agenda behind every single movie when
you watched them i i think the grooming
has improved more than anything so
we got it gerard yeah i mean we got we
got a lot of stories here and what are
the chances of us starting with football
brady belichick basic instinct sorry for
bringing this show down guys this is
incredible
did you do anything fun last week
what did we do last week dylan's
birthday are you talking rogan oh yes
you're talking rogan we had a good time
yes we had a good time did you did you
watch the whole thing oh man i look
you're gonna think it goes you know i
like him we're friends and stuff like
that but i'm a big rogan fan that was
one of the best broken episodes it
really was tell me a lot you guys vibed
man you guys look seem like old buddies
for like like you were hanging out with
like a dude from uh from the barracks
back in the day yeah he he was really
engaged
i mean he just
abnormally engaged i thought what was in
the cup was that water in the cup
it was vodka committed to my heritage
you know i uh
austin
when you went in there how long did you
think the interview was going to last i
have no idea i mean i you you don't you
don't think from that standpoint but
literally we're both talking all of a
sudden you look at the clock i'm like oh
[ __ ] i want to be late to my flight
because they told me if i don't get to
the uh uh
the
uh
private airport by five o'clock that's
done i have to stay overnight i'm like i
got board meetings the next day so
uh i had meetings the next day uh uh
that we had to handle but yeah we made
it it was incredible the conversation
was great he's the ultimate renaissance
man today the guy is what arrows hunting
ufc mma
you know the us open taekwondo champion
you know the guys everywhere he doesn't
know sports and he doesn't do nfts
that's what i learned about the sports
doesn't do an ftc
but he's officially got an anthony
voucher rookie card that's cute she's
the hottest man in the world
he's going to keep talking about it
until it gets up up the uh
was it was he the same off air or was he
was it cool same guy just the same guy
man you know the best the best people
are those that they're just the way they
are no matter what whether the camera's
on or not
same guy just chill you know
strong opinions curiosity at the highest
level
great exchange great conversation and it
seemed like
you were asking him as many questions he
was asking you he's more like
pat interviews
yeah
dude i mean
i'm curious i want to know what this
guy's thinking i want to know how
you know when when you think about the
most necessary people in america i got
him at the top of the list
he's forcing the conversation to be had
he is forcing you to have the
conversation think about that yeah
without a political agenda as a starter
you got a respect doesn't have that no
he's telling you hey listen guys you
disagree let's have the conversation how
many people are doing that today versus
screw you you have no clue what you're
talking about i don't ever want to talk
to you no he says come on let's talk
yeah plus he's enlightened going through
covid and the treatment that he had he
has a really interesting perspective on
that yeah it's pretty clear that uh you
said listen calling the other side an
idiot
never will convert the other side yeah i
know he's not a fan of trump he's
definitely not a fan of biden apparently
he's a big fan of joe jorgensen in front
of the show yeah all right i got to push
back on that though for both of you guys
i do have to push back let's hear it
don't get canceled we will cancel you
right now son on your birthday one part
one part of it that i did agree with is
that that's a learned trait you have to
learn to give your your opponents credit
and i do believe at the end of the day
that you can learn how to do this yeah
you do need it's a learned trait and i
think we do need synergy but i think
also
we lived in a moment and we're still
living in a moment where people
weaponized and empathy where an entire
group of people took people's kindness
as a weakness and at some point you had
to be firm you had to be able to tell
somebody no
put your put your two inch earrings away
and your purple hair and shut the hell
up all right you had to you had to get
firm with people and you had to be like
no this is stupid i'm not doing what
you're telling me to do anymore i've
done it i've done it i've done it i've
acquiesced enough now i'm saying no and
if you push back again i'm gonna say no
firmer i think at some point they pushed
too far they took too much advantage and
now the other side had to get nasty with
them had to match that energy now from
there once there's a mutual respect once
you understand that hey look enough's
enough and i am if you're committed to
disrupting my lifestyle i'm committed to
living my lifestyle and then the chips
far where they may and then you can have
synergy from there that that's just my
opinion i think you need to find a local
mma place to go train because i think
you have a lot of you you got rage you
got to release you got to go fight a lot
of anger after seven o'clock you and him
should just wrestle and fight and yeah
that's what i'm looking to do with my
spare time yeah i saw this freaking
grizzly bear all you have to do just
tell gerard belichick sucks and it's on
yeah david parra over there to his
credit
david took the challenge oh yeah that
was big time he wouldn't he wouldn't do
it a scarcity wouldn't do it i said look
a hundred dollars the three of you guys
take me down three versus one hundred
dollars each you're getting all comment
the same oh wait wait who was it david
who else david and paul paul and nancy
and adam and nancy and manchester united
adam was the first out nancy said no and
then like the commie she is waited for
david to engage and then tried to kick
my knees yeah so david to his credit at
least it's a good strategy david came
all the way in he he he he went into the
cage well you got to respect that you
got to respect him i'm thinking i'm
filming some segments tomorrow i'm
trying to go out to the club this
weekend have a good time the last thing
i'm doing in my spare time is wrestling
is grizzly today by the way it could be
done with a little strategy you just
have someone sneak behind them kneel
down and you push them over i mean
it could be times better strategy
buddy guys how about how about we get
into some topics that's okay with you
let's get into some topics kai whenever
our friend from australia is ready you
let me know i'm going to do one topic
then we're going to our friend
from australia okay
so let's go into new york
and nyu professor says fewer men going
to college will lead to a mating crisis
with the u.s producing too many broke
and alone
men is what this professor says let's
see where he's going with this because
the numbers are pretty staggering when
you look at the graduating class this is
an insider story fewer men than women
are attending college which is leading
to a mating crisis the new york
professor scott galloway said women made
up 59.5 of college students at the end
of 2021 school year that's 60 an
all-time high
uh with a comparison to 40 of men
enrolled in college but galloway warned
that beyond the classroom the gap is
causing
an existential threat to society so the
the issue i have with the college thing
right is talk about a bunch of [ __ ]
this dude first of all the reason why
these women at nyu don't want to have
kids is because the college professors
are telling them that their job is more
important than anything that they're
going to do as a family they have
brainwashed an entire generation into
thinking these women have to have a a
career or a family that they somehow
can't have a career and a family that's
number one number two this idea that
because you don't go to college you're
somehow gonna end up broke and alone
like truckers aren't making 250 grand a
year like soldiers aren't out there
getting laid like plumbers aren't out
there with mansions dude this is the
biggest the the higher education upright
upper echelon education in america is
maybe the biggest issue in our entire
culture because all they do is funnel
ideology and it's non-stop social
pressure come to college do what we tell
you to do fit in do anything that we say
otherwise your life is women aren't
gonna like you no job's gonna hire you
and then those are the same people that
turn around and they think communism is
the only way because capitalism's
failing them because some idiot plumber
makes more money than they do as a phd
in in basket weaving it's all bs this
guy just exposed everything here's my
question
okay
scott galloway isn't one of those
typical liberal college professors you
know who's scott galbraith don't yeah
he's he's a mischievous director
he's a liberal don't don't get me wrong
he's he's a liberal but he's not he's
got very good points he's makes we we we
love scott galloway go ahead yeah no
he's an intelligent guy he's a deep
thinker now he also knows how to get
attention and this clearly served its
purpose because i saw him interviewed on
cnn and they almost treated him like an
ally which i didn't expect to see you
know the thing that caught my eye adam
touched on it a little bit but he
equated what's happening as far as the
uh the disconnect between the proportion
of men and women getting their degrees
to what happens in the most violent
countries and violent societies and
saying that this is like the worst
characteristic you can have because it
leads to unbelievable violence the other
point that he brought up that was really
interesting is the acceptance rates into
college right it is so hard for people
to get into some of these good colleges
right now when he went to school he
referenced the fact that it was a 70
acceptance rate at ucla now it's 14
so it's not it's not as easy as just
saying hey i want to do this because you
know they're going after exceptionalism
and that's what he said the problem is
right now is the colleges are only
accepting exceptionalism and that that's
going to be a big problem going forward
can you see go ahead before i tell you
you uh give your point kai can you pull
up
a statistic on men or women historically
graduating with a four-year degree see
if you can get like a 50
euro
number for us to see go ahead adam yeah
i think everyone's made some some valid
points i think the most important thing
is that we're actually having this
discussion for so long
it was you have to go to college you
have to do this there was a blueprint to
be successful not so true anymore now
you can go to trade schools and be
successful you talked about plumbers or
truckers technicians and hvac's people
can make a hundred grand a year making
more than a college degree even for a
lot of people um
it's it's the conversations needed you
talked about scott galloway i believe
he's the guy that we read his article a
few months ago about graduates need to
be warriors not wokesters that's the
same guy kai yes yes okay so he's not
some woke liberal nyu professor or
anything like that let me be the point
that's not what i was saying i'm not
saying that you were saying that i'm
just saying about him he's been very
vocal of uh he he he does like what's
your point though not now give like
conversation is needed however
let's let's bring this back who's this
needed for
34 year olds
don't need to learn about this because
you're already freaking graduated
17 and 18 year old young men or even
women need to be paying attention to
this so our younger crowd our younger
audience needs to understand all right
this is a perspective should i go to
college should i not go to college one
of the greatest videos you've ever done
pat was why college is a scam maybe it
is let me tell you if i'm going to
college at ucla and at the 60 40 ratio
checks sign me up yeah right that's
going to motivate some kids guys two
points just to let me clarify i'm not
anti-education i am not anti-education
okay but the the idea that college is
somehow the only way to get educated is
nonsensical man all right we all know
that
do we
education in in america today exists for
two things all right in my mind not to
paint with a broad brush interesting to
make people obedient and that's why
there's less crime it's it's an
obedience school it's a finishing school
okay it teaches people how to be good
employees and you know listen to
authority and the other side of it is is
it sales education right half of the
point of education the only job you can
get is to go into education and then
sell it's a giant ponzi scheme but but
to me i'm going pure logic okay let's go
pure logic set aside the emotion look at
the stats guys can you guys flip it
toward the screen to show this chart
please okay um
and and jorge do me a favor next time
don't put this in here because my leg
hits it especially when we got four
um so if you look at this it says
percentage of u.s population
who have completed four years of college
or more from 1940 to 2020 okay that's 80
years
if you look at it it was closer matter
of fact we were not even going to
college 80 years ago so only 5.5 of the
population
male 1 graduated from college and only
3.8 percent of women graduated college
so if you put the two together 5.5 plus
3.8 is what nine point uh 503.8 is a 3.8
so 9.3 what's 5.5 divided by nine point
three do five point five divided by nine
point three
fifty five sixty percent by ninety three
so it used to be sixty fifty nine
percent men
uh uh uh uh forty one percent women and
on this poll blue uh
it's blue is
female yeah so but but go to
the the separation has been so don't let
the separation look like a big number
because it's still the same ratio like
5.5 on 3 8 is the same ratio but it
looks like it's closer
we've been the same so the real change
happened what year the real change
happened in 2008 okay so what happened
in norway that's all i want to know i
mean if you go to waste and you is it
the housing crisis but what are the
housing crisis oh you know what
presidential change obama came in okay
so obama came and obama was if you
remember when obama came obama said you
know uh uh to get more degrees in
uh what was he saying education lawyer
you know go be a teacher go be a nurse
go be there in oh wait people
the gap close and more people who
started going to school so so then obama
effect obama encouraged people to get
graduates i mean college but also
something to think about there was no
jobs the job markets suck so people were
like what the hell am i going to do with
myself all i'm telling you is i'm
looking at data right now and then now
women flip and they're taking a lead
with men okay
so why let's let's let's process that
from the standpoint of why on one end
uh
when did it become
when when was the push male female what
year is that 15 14 female took over in
15 14 go back to 15
even 15 14 yeah 14 women were ahead of
men so when did the push become to say
men and women are equal when did that
push out because that was in the 60s
that was in the 60s okay so if you go
from 60s
so you got the push from there to when
did the push become for women to become
executives entrepreneurs
what was that third wave feminism is
early 90s mid 90s third wave feminism
would you say third wave feminism is in
early 90s yeah myself i should know this
my sister's gonna be so mad at me okay
but but whatever the stat may be there's
a reason for this so it's greater and
then what this leads to
the more independence i was talking to
this guy marion toopey i think his name
is he wrote this book 10 uh
trends to pay attention to and one of
the numbers was the fact that he said by
20 to uh 2100 america's the world's only
got nine billion people living in or
seven billion people living in it based
on how many kids people are having so
women becoming more career oriented when
it comes down to a decision i was
talking to a very powerful woman in
america one disclosure name we're having
dinner together and i said that why
don't you have any kids she says i
wanted to compete with men and i knew if
i would have had kids i wouldn't be able
to compete with men because i don't want
to give up that 90 days and then having
to raise a kid and not being able to
stay after the office i want to compete
with them and because of that i made it
to the top of my field and i beat a lot
of my male peers okay so now if that
competition happens
and a baby's being born per
that number drops to 1.5 1.4 1.7 this is
when the population starts decreasing
rather than increasing so we have to be
around 2.4
per family for it to increase so 2.4
kids per family 2.4 for the population
to start increasing you start increasing
at one point this is why you look at
right now the
uh the age the the oldest country in the
world from the super powers is china
36.8 is the average age if you want to
pull up china's average age because they
did the one baby because they did the
one baby now they're back to two babies
by the way and you know they're thinking
about going to three babies but you got
the uh 38.4 i think u.s is 38.1
go to u.s now us's
average age average age u.s is
38.1 and then go to india now look at
india's average age it's like 26. that's
26 exactly what it is 26.4 28.4 japan
japan's is old by the way kai's killing
it today oh he misspelled japan what
what happened so close guys
i'm saying 40. they are the oldest
country if you have two kids and your
wife gets pregnant in china what kind of
oldest country
is that's actually a good question i
think back in the
day it's not close i mean that was a
very strict rule uh japan's 40 japan is
the oldest country 45 5 italy go to the
youngest
go to the youngest who's at the bottom
niger 15 chad uganda a lot of african
countries afghanistan is 16 and a half
this is why china loves afghanistan with
all lithium
zimbab zambia who else is at the top
that say
nigeria 17 8 keep going
uh
congo
kenya sudan guatemala's 194 shout out to
mario and uh rose right that's rose's
birthday today rose happy birthday to
you rose happy birthday to you rose okay
and then we got ecuador 26 and then you
got india 22. where's china on this list
china's 38 ford we looked at that
already okay so they're in the middle of
the list kind of japan go back to top
guy
japan is the oldest country
and then germany colombia if you have
one seven that number keeps decreasing
okay countries gotta average 2.4 or
higher okay so you both of you guys are
kind of screwed the whole thing up
that's why you're stepping up we have 12
kids
did i see that colombia's average age is
23 kai well what i've learned from
hanging out with adam is that colombia
definitely has the best banter
out of any country see poppy yeah you
know what one one thing about this is
what about the acceptance uh you would
think the admissions departments of all
these major universities would be
cognizant of this and trying to
change the the percentage a little bit
admit more guys
i think that's way way after i think
they're like step nine okay then what
about what about the cost and how that's
inhibiting this as well because there is
so much pressure on kids right now to
get into the college they want to it's
internal pressure they're feeling it
from their parents and they are
definitely feeling it from their peers i
mean it controls teenagers lives in some
communities it really does if you're
getting accepted to college into the
right college their perceived mind and
you have one daughter that's graduated
college and uh correct ivana
is she's 15. so she's she's a sophomore
right now 10 12 he's 12. he's 12 years
old i just i really i really take a lot
of umbrage with the fact that this guy
somehow equates not going to college
with somehow ending up being broke and
alone like like like going to college is
the only way that you're not going to be
stupid well i would argue with you but i
got to go define umbrage real quick i'll
be right back so this is the thing i
gotta go change my umbrage if you if you
have if you have an internet connection
you have an education yeah true if you
have a computer
you have an education what he's
referring to is this disparity and that
eventually is gonna cause a problem as
opposed to trying to force everybody to
go to college i think he's looking at
the 60 40 and saying there's an issue
down the road
when i my senior college you know what
as i realized i had completely wasted
all the money in time just on on hanging
out and playing baseball and partying
was
i spent four years in college learning
from and about people throughout history
who never went to college what phd does
tesla have
like benjamin franklin i'm reading i'm
reading the federal freaking point
i'm reading the federalist papers and
i'm and i'm enthralled in my political
science class with the percentage of the
population
in 1540
one percent is that it was there even
college that that is the point i'm
trying to make
you know the the to the auto didact of
the world where
you know you study on your own and
you're curious you're always wanting to
learn and it's a never-ending thing
versus you've got four years to learn
and the rest of your life it's going to
set you up and probably you know all
this stuff a couple of points
just real quick we have confused as a
society
access to information with education
like the ability to be able to google
something memorize it for 24 hours and
regurgitate it on a test it's not
knowing anything i agree let me get a
phone so i can call this australia go
ahead and you have two points you have a
couple good points here that that
college doesn't equal education back in
the day when we were growing up y'all we
had encyclopedias that was our or we had
the car
door-to-door exactly
now you've got don't walk on this you've
got to go no
one thing that that you know college
isn't just about education it's just not
about being book smart it's about being
social smart yeah a lot of colleges
understanding
who to be friends with how to network
who not to hang out with how to maybe
start a business how to
you know how to interact in the club how
to go approach a girl how many people
these days never even know how to call a
girl or talk to a girl because it's all
online and and dating apps what have you
you got to spend a couple years getting
just rejected and yes
real time yeah but and college will
teach you all these things that that you
won't not you hear about that
or what happened to him did you guys
hear the story about shaq and sure he
got blown up shaq went on tinder he says
i tried tinder he said so i reached out
to this one girl i liked she was pretty
and she responded back and says shaq
would never be on tinder get the hell
out of here says i got off tinder
because nobody believed
hey can you play that video from the
guardian on what happened with australia
so so at the end are you going to send
your kids to college and support it yeah
yeah you are you got to be like yes when
you have kids you're going to be like i
don't know i i think
by in 20 years from now we'll see what
there were the games at but but for you
like is are you going to be encouraging
it are you going to say do whatever you
want to do uh
i'm i'm trade school military army
entrepreneurship college i'm growing
entrepreneurs pat that's it all right
how about you i don't know if you heard
this but a hundred percent of the
world's problems are going to be solved
by entrepreneurs i actually agree with
whoever said that by the way you know
you know what i think gerard's answer is
going to be 100 of his kids are going to
go to uc berkeley yes yes
yes or no oh man can you imagine that
i'd love to see them when they come back
and see that
hey dad you're clueless you have no clue
what you're talking about you're so
selfish
yeah twitter
just go on my twitter
what about you you answer this question
yeah going to college with dylan
he's already going to college now that
their private school is 75 grand a year
he's going to do the universities
the amount of amount of books these guys
have read yes valence score came the
other day when we're doing the teacher
you know you know when you're doing your
what do you call this stuff when you're
sitting out with the teacher and they
give you parents here's where you here's
the organization here's where the
average student is in america here's
where the average student's in our
school and here's where average student
is here's where your kid is at right so
it was boom boom boom dylan [ __ ]
billy he's an interesting does better
grades than i ever do
is also good i have thought about this
and this is this is the truth if he if
he or she wants to be a lawyer or a
doctor go to college if you don't know
what you want to do if you're going to
be a communications major kite engineer
engineering i spend 10 grand
go go coder backpack through europe for
six months so your roads that way learn
how to party and network doing that
it'll cost you a lot less money then
come back man and be an electrician and
be retired by 45 bro but you know what
i'm talking about the communications
materials what the hell is your video
internship without it yeah that one's
classic how's your day going what the
hell is that those gators i just i just
think so much of what we do is wrong
like we were taught if anybody if you
had to go into a trade you were somehow
a loser you know you you failed you gave
up on life now you know if i had to do
over it was army though army was like
you're a dummy right you're not the
you're it you're not the smartest the
last stop saloon man
zero
15 years they got three houses they're
killing it man you look at something my
buddy's got a wife he's got kids he's
got he's got a house when he got married
early at 24 you're like dude what are
you doing you're throwing your life away
now he's like five years away from
retirement his kids are going to be 18
they're going to be out of the house
he's going to he's going to have a
pension he's killing it guys just send
it to you so
nelson rodriguez just gave 2 20 5 bucks
is pregnancy after two children she can
be forced to get an abortion also will
force sterilization it's also common for
women to have unregistered children
that doesn't exist child gets no benefit
including education this is china nelson
is that is that verifiable like my god
and who wants hey nelson can you send
the link to verify this uh so we can
check that channel wasn't playing around
with it okay so check this out watch
this video this is what just happened to
in australia and and when i posted this
i said can somebody verify this this is
a guardian
video that they have go ahead
because she doesn't have a mask on
australia
he's
joe would be impressed with that kick
right there that's your tax dollars at
work australia
australians are funding that with the
hours of their lives
yeah what are you doing now watching
what the guy says
yeah but you're choking you're choking
her there's a man on the gut as a man on
a girl it's a man on a girl and you
choked her
but what for a mask for not having a
mask look how pathetic you are she
doesn't have a mask are you serious are
you serious just for not having a mask
are you [ __ ] serious this is a
disturbing video by the way so folks if
you watch this that's a let's call
george
that issue adishi from
australia okay
uh uh
let's see if george if you're speaking i
he's picked up so i don't know if you
guys can hear him on our because i
cannot
yeah good morning gents george how are
you
good good patrick so brother can you
take a second tell us your background
like five seconds your background and
tell us what's going on in australia
yeah look i um like to
i i was actually born in sydney um lived
there for probably the first 35 years of
my life and then actually i've had to
move into state for work but um
yeah i in the uh i'm i'm
i guess one of the fortunate ones more
in the white collar and in a good area
but um not feeling the same for
the rest of the family unfortunately um
yeah sydney's sydney in particular has
been in shambles uh locked up i think
it's in week 15 now
where you're not able to actually travel
longer than i think about five
kilometers
away from home
um
yeah they're rewarding some industries
over here with uh you know you can only
work but if you if you're double jabbed
so that's um
that's that's caused some issues but
it's rewarding some people are not
others and then you've got areas also in
some of the more affluent areas in
sydney which are not being really
enforced the rules where you know places
you know that are considered more blue
collar have the army and uh you know
high-level police tactics units
patrolling the streets making sure that
people are living by the rules so george
the video we saw this is not everywhere
in australia this is just pocket so so
let me let me give you maybe optics for
us in the state so in america
california new york we know how they're
doing new york governor yesterday
announced that they're going to be
firing the unvaccinated health workers
and national guard guard's going to come
out and a lot of people are leaving new
york a lot of people are leaving
california
and some are going to texas some are
going to arizona some are going to
greenwich some are going to d.c some are
going to florida some are going
tennessee they're going all over the
place what states are more like the new
york and california of australia and
what areas are more like the texas and
florida of australia
yeah no good question so the um the
places that are more like california are
places like victoria so melbourne a lot
of people would know melbourne
uh is one of the sort of um very similar
to california
and um sydney unfortunately wasn't like
that previously but it's actually turned
more
more uh
more liberal i guess if you want to use
that term um the places where people are
moving to are generally more north so
places like queensland so you've got a
big influx of people moving into
brisbane and gold coast
um
which are like the more warmer areas and
a little bit more freedom uh to move
around and do what you want
how how bad are in uh are things in
those areas where
you said uh uh more liberal how bad are
things like how how are they uh you know
you hear stories about lockdown you've
not been able to leave your house for
eight weeks 12 weeks
you know we read about it but we're not
in australia to know what's going on
what would you say is really happening
over there for some of us that are not
in australia
yeah look it's
i guess what they're trying to force at
the moment is compliance and so even
people who don't or have been
traditionally against uh you know the
recent job um
you know are being forced to do so only
because it means that they have to put
food on the table so as you mentioned
before
but there are
you know if you're not if you don't have
the job
companies are giving you a deadline
they're saying if you don't have it by
for example the fifth of october
uh you'll be automatically resigned from
your position and you'll need to find
employment elsewhere so they're they're
saying they're giving you a choice but
they're not really you know they're
they're saying to you well the choices
here is either take the job and go
against your principles
or
uh don't put food on the table
and so a lot of people are saying well
we have to make the sacrifice we need to
put a roof over our heads and you know
feed our families
so we're going to have to you know have
to take it is there major protesting
going on or no are people just kind of
sitting back and are too concerned that
if they push back too much something
could happen to them and their families
yeah no it's um so they have been
protests specifically in victoria
and melbourne which is probably where
you've seen
some of the heavy-handed tactics there
new south wales as well
has also had protests but the police
have done a really good job of actually
finding
some of the ringleaders and finding them
quite severely and putting others in
jail
um
you know some of the fines here are very
expensive so you know for those that
aren't already working then having to to
fork out money for a fine is
you know it's it's heartbreaking what
kind of fines are we talking about
oh it's you know five thousand dollars
five thousand dollars we're not getting
vaccination
no no no for out for out protesting so
you know trying to you know protesting
for you know giving a lot of these
people are already vaccinated and but
but what they're protesting is you know
people to have free will to have the
ability to choose whether to take or not
to take so
you know unfortunately
the police are doing a good job of
ensuring that
you know people aren't out there
protesting and we're not hearing we're
only hearing what's happening in the
mainstream media a lot of the protests
you know what you mentioned earlier is
they're actually being restricted from
being put on social media so unless if
you're actually at the protest or you
know someone directly at the protest
you're not hearing about it you're not
finding out about
what's happening on the streets the
heavy-handed tactics you'll see a lot of
the
the media
is actually being
you know you know taken the videos are
being taken by individuals who are then
posting it up um onto more of the uh
the freedom
you know the free kind of social media
george this is uh adam i was like i'm
gonna ask you that exact question
there's a good friend of mine who lives
in sydney he's keeping me very
informed of what's going on there's i
guess there's a journalist verified in
australia sophie ellsworth
she said this is talking about melbourne
that from today's
protest no live vision
of melbourne's protest will be allowed
to be aired a directive of the victoria
police which has been deemed a form of
media censorship so my question is
where are you seeing all this stuff
what's going on in the media is it on tv
is it on social media or friends passing
it's around
the fact that they won't even show
protests
that's i mean that's some big brother
stuff right there what are your thoughts
george yeah yeah
yeah no adam it's it's definitely
friends passing it on to other friends
um it's not you're definitely not seeing
it on mainstream media or you're not
seeing it on the the main networks uh
it's friend passing it on to a friend
who is passing it on to another friend
that's the only way you're able to see
some of the live footage have you had
any interaction with police or anything
like that that have been disturbing or
your friends have been like the one
video we saw the of the lady getting
choked out because she didn't have a
mask do you have any stories like that
or your friends have any stories like
that
yeah no definitely have not not myself
personally but um like direct friends of
mine um who've been who've actually been
arrested and taken to court for you know
refusing to follow police instructions
and um you know sometimes they're
enforcing rules so the rules are sort of
on and off all the time you know like um
for example up in queensland at the
moment um the rules the the mask wearing
rules have been more strictly enforced
uh because we've had three new capers up
in up in queensland what percentage of
australians agree with this tactic it it
would i would see assume it's
a decent majority or a decent number if
they're allowing this what are your
thoughts
uh i wouldn't say adam i mean it's it's
unfortunately it's the silent the silent
minority that are making a lot of the
noise so
um yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't say and
we're sort of following a lot of what
the minority are doing uh or want us to
do so give us a procedure
oh look i'd say i'd say it's probably
about
it it might be 40 60 so 40 percent want
these strip rules and the other 60 just
want to be left alone to do their own
thing
um but all we're hearing is about the 40
percent
and what on what they want has covet
actually declined meaning are they
actually making progress with fewer
cases and fewer deaths
uh uh in regards to cobit
uh
last last year in 2020 we didn't hear
about too many deaths um
you know where it was sort of young
people i think the average age of uh
people dying from covert up here in or
down here in australia is i think it's
in the 80s
so it's it's hard to it's hard to say
patrick if it's crazy if they're covered
type yeah their covert type deaths or
their uh you know deaths from other
from other i guess
average age of people joining us in the
80s george this girardi we've never
asked you to speculate on that man thank
you so much for for taking the time by
the way to help us you know understand
this on a global scale i know we have a
lot of listeners out there that are that
are very confused
um the the quarantine camps out there do
you know anybody that's been inside of
the quarantine camps what it's like out
there is this something that that
uh it has been over reported under
reported can can you give me any idea on
what that situation is like where there
are actual
camps where they're taking people who i
suppose have have tested positive or
actually in in some cases from one i've
read haven't tested positive they've
just been around people who have tested
positive and they've been removed from
society and put in these camps for weeks
at a time
yeah it's definitely underreported we
don't we don't hear too much about it i
think what they did is a few months ago
they did actually ask you know they did
put it out into mainstream media and i
don't think the
the feedback was overly positive so we
haven't really heard too much about it
since
um
yeah they're really controlling the
narrative there yeah by the way i just
looked at the number kai if you go to
statistia
and you type in i typed in the following
search i typed an average age of covet
that's uh in australia and if you go
down to the statistia website
uh
if you go average average it's right
there age of
um
that's in uh
australia you got to go to australia
okay
while you guys are bringing that up
we're actually finding out later down
the track
um after the media's reported we've had
you know for example one death in one
part of sydney
you're actually finding out later that
that person actually didn't die from
covert they may have had covert certain
time but they've had historical heart
issues for example or they were cancer
patients and so it's it's hard to tell
or they had a motorcycle
yeah they did they die from covert or
did they die with poverty it's it and
they've tried to make that distinguish
yeah they've tried to distinguish that's
right by the way right here if you look
at this the statistic statista
shows that number of cover debts that
took place
by age majority are over 90 and over 80.
look at the and then over 70 and look at
the drop off when you go to 60 and below
wait wait are those in the thousands or
is that 200 200 people
number of people should respond to
september 2017. that that would be
number of people number two 100 people
in a there's 25 million people in
australia
and that's over 80 just over the age of
this is september 2021. so if you if you
calculate this male and females they'd
say that's 210
say that's 450
say that's 350. so say 800
1100 right there and then you have at
the bottom here is say uh a hundred say
a hundred
out of the 1200 people that have died
are under the age of 70. yeah older and
then 90 of people that died are above
the age of 70. and they and they can't
go out after nine o'clock at night the
entire country is locked down on
military law
george let's uh maybe uh try to think
positive i guess in three weeks from now
uh apparently on october 18th there's
something going to be called freedom's
day and apparently that's when 80
percent of the population will be fully
vaccinated and apparently your
airports are going to be open for the
first time in two years i guess uh
fourth quarter of this year what do you
know about this freedom's day in this
eighty percent uh yeah benchmark stay
strong there george the first nine
months of two weeks to flatten the curve
of the hardest buddy
yeah
yeah now look it's um
it's it's a carrot atom there but the
carrot's been moved a few times um so
i'll believe it when i see it
unfortunately um but yeah they've
there's a few times they've made
promises when we get to 70 and then they
moved it to 75 into 80. so
who knows but if when we get to 80 it
might then become 85 we just don't know
um
well george appreciate you buddy
brother thank you
george
nassima thank you uh just two two things
pat just to finish off first of all
obviously happy birthday to dylan thank
you um you know wish you all the best
and also i want to wish uh my son jonah
happy seventh birthday as well
jonah happy birthday buddy by the way
it's also rose's birthday it's also
gerard's birthday today and today is
also gerard's birthday and like what a
special day by the way jonah happy
birthday to you gerard and rose george
once again thank you for your time
brother happy birthday all around thank
you thank you thank you thank you
adam wanted to leave him on a positive
note and i'll leave him on a positive
note to all the great people of
australia i've never met a single
australian in my life that wasn't
awesome by the way man the great people
australia there are 65 000 police
officers on that island there are 25
million 0.5 million australians
apes together strong
yeah you know you you teed them up to
give you them some hope and then they
just keep pushing that that
that that little why wouldn't they tom i
know
dude guys the whole world's and this
goes back to what i was talking about
about before pat were you talking about
be a synergist and and i get that i
really really do but some points
somebody's got to be a catalyst they
will not they're not going to stop
they're not going to stop you have to
force them to stop you have to bully the
book by the way let's let's talk about
this so if i were to tell you
a year ago okay
that the person that's pushing back
for the people to have the option to not
get vaccinated in the nba was going to
be kyrie irving would you have believed
it if i told you europe initially i
would not yeah initially i would have
believed anything that against the grain
would be kyrie irving well there's a lot
of things to go against the grain that
he's going for it so so for me with
kyrie being that guy andrew wiggins
being that guy stephen a saying you got
to fire these guys or trade them because
zeal too yeah bradley beale two and
there's a few other guys that are quiet
of the league probably yeah so kyrie was
asked the question kyrie was asked a
question about
new york city because the challenge is
what city you're playing in right so
kyrie irving could consider skipping
some home games over new york city
vaccine mandates this is a new york
daily mail article new york city has a
vaccine mandate for venues like the
barclays
center players on the next and nets may
must be vaccinated play home games and
enter home marinas the knicks say 100
their players and staff are vaccinated
nets gm sean marx admits that not
that's not the case with his team
according to a fox sports story on
thursday irving is one of those
unvaccinated players and while marx are
confident it wouldn't be an issue new
york's mandate simply requires proof of
one dose a report from rolling stone
indicates it would be more complicated
irving's aunt taiki
irving all but confirmed her nephew is
proudly i'm unvaccinated she is the
executive director of kyrie irving's kai
family foundation which leads irving's
extensive charity towards blacks
environmental and many other causes taki
said that kyrie support uh supposed the
injection to vaccination was not
religious space it's moral base unlike
andrew wiggins then irving will sim uh
seemingly not seek a religious exemption
to a city's indoor vaccine requirements
and weekends requests for religious
exemptions was rejected by the nba
anyway they asked him a question
yesterday they said so kyrie
are you planning on getting the vaccine
you know what his answer was uh you know
i appreciate that question uh that's a
personal uh question and i'd like to
keep that to myself
because it's a personal matter of my
family so what do you think about what
kyrie's up to i think it's a major
problem in the nba uh it's gonna get
really really bad here's why because the
nba pa is protecting the players so
mandating vaccinations for nba players
will never happen it's a non-starter the
le the union is very staunch in the fact
that that's not going to happen so now
what's happening is you're having a lot
union president is it still paul or is
it who is uh yes i believe it's still
chris paul as a player but they have a
very it's um cj mccollum now is it or
he's the next maybe i mean they're the
leadership committee for the nba as far
as the players and but there's a
full-time job someone might get a couple
million that that is you know executive
over all of this whoever it is lebron
james right eventually uh so
kyrie irving showed up via zoom
yesterday he didn't show up at media day
he as of right now he can't play their
home games he can't play against the
knicks and he can't play against the
warriors and they're saying about 10 of
the league right now is not going to get
vaccinated and the problem is you it's
mandated for coaches and administrators
referees and everything like that you
are going to see so much friction now
from front office personnel that are
upset that they might in their minds be
exposed to the virus by these players
that aren't vaccinated and it's the
season's two weeks from starting so
these games are going to be missed very
very soon and it's only going to get
worse because they will not bradley beal
is not going to get vaccinated andrew
wiggins will not get vaccinated and he's
already been rejected for asking for a
religious exemption he didn't get it so
the line has been drawn in the sand and
and he's got a big big problem in the
nba to deal with this and keep these
players happy and prevent a revolt
because that's where it's going
adam who's going to be revolting you
think um the people that are vaccinated
have very strong feelings about it
against the people that refused the
players the small of players
the people are going to be pushing back
i think are the
the the
older
personnel or older coaches with older
family members or with young kids that
they're concerned with 90 of the nba has
been vaccinated so you're hearing a
couple
voices come out there that have not been
vaccinated a lot of teams i think that
look the bottom line is people have an
issue with
mandates that's what we're talking about
here if you want to get vaccinated get
vaccinated if you don't want to do it
you don't have to do it you don't have
to jab your body if you don't want to do
it bradley beal came out and he actually
was dude so smooth so chill he's like
look i'm not getting vaccinated i had
covered i'm good very monotone chill
he's like my parents got it my aunt's
got it my uncle's got it i'm just not
getting it you're good
if he doesn't want to get it and he's
calm and collective about it
what type of reasoning do you have to
force someone to get it that's the
problem what type of reason does anybody
have to force anybody to do anything if
this isn't a medical issue to your point
you're 100 right medical issue has gone
out the window this is a civil rights
issue this is the civil rights issue of
our life this is something we just
talked about china imagine a situation
imagine an environment where you have to
ask the government's permission to have
kids you wouldn't have brooklyn would
not be allowed in your life
you would have to ask their permission
if it's okay for you and your wife to
bring life into this world i mean we
we're literally i mean it's a joke that
they're telling us how to breathe
how are we allowed to breathe we're
allowed to go outside if we sit down you
can breathe with no mask covet floats
it's in the air if you're under five
foot never have to wear a mask obviously
because covet floats right
how you're allowed to breathe what
you're allowed to do how are you allowed
to work we have to push back
biden's saying that when are we getting
back to normal did you hear what he said
97 vaccinated
97 percent
if we don't push back why would they
ever stop and i'll tell you what support
these players support them support be
support beasley up and up in buffalo
even if you think this medication is the
greatest medication of all time and it
might be
it's it's not okay this is this is not
okay at all that we're allowing social
stratification based on what the elites
want and what they don't to be clear
you're you're you're
again this goes back to mandates someone
wants to do it they should do it dude
it's more than mandates this is this
goes way beyond mandates this is way
beyond mandates this is social
stratification this is for those of us
that don't know what that is what is
social stratification this this is
aristocrats and plebeians this is jim
crow this is
vaccinated you know front of the bus
unvaccinated back of the bus this is the
the
teammates okay if you believed in any
sort of segregation all right if you
thought when you watched jackie robinson
when you watched the movie and you said
that that would never be me i would
never be one of those people that looks
at jackie robinson that says he can't
eat in here he this is this is this is a
a whites-only diner all right and you
thought you you saw that happen and you
said that is horrible that's the plural
how could those people do that and
you're one of these people that would
kick a vaccine an unvaccinated person
out of the restaurant right now guess
what you know exactly who you are you're
fine with segregation you're fine with
social stratification i see your point i
do think that's a stretch though however
i do see your point i think there's to
equate
full-on racism
and
prejudice and bigotry with
hey if you're not vaccinated you can't
be here a lot of these businesses have
the choice to say look sorry if you're
not vaccinated you can't come in that's
what's going on in new york city right
now dude they have that choice okay but
you have to understand that argument was
made for racism oh you know they're
these they just don't have the education
that we have they they grow up they're
dirty people like you can you could
justify
any sort of segregation any sort it
could be justified it's the people who
look at it and say man i i i'm not gonna
no absolutely not i don't care this is
my brother this is this is this is my
friend he's an american
he has the right they're going to have
his life they're going to have to
prepare themselves for the fact that
games are going to be altered because of
this i mean they're not going to change
their mind all right how are the wizards
going to win without bradley beal half
their games good or in new york yes yeah
we've got better than an nba regular
season game kyrie is very cool missing
40 games a season well that would just
be a normal problem
okay
so you know i could see a guy like steve
kerr losing his mind with andrew wiggins
yeah not getting vaccinated ask you a
question why why does new york need the
national guard to replace unvaccinated
health workers don't don't go conspiracy
just go simple
uh
you're regular person you don't look
into conspiracies you don't think 911 or
jfk you just you just follow black and
white
why does new york
say we may use national guard to replace
unvaccinated health warfare my first
thought would be to create the illusion
that this is the a crisis of the highest
order and that if they had to bring in
the national guard then you have to
believe us about how bad this is
that that was my first but to replace
him is what if if this crisis is half as
bad as as we're you know meant to
believe it is then imagine actually
saying you know the the hospitals are
busting out of the gills so we're going
to fire half of our staff and who knows
more about this and replace them with
untrained medical professionals yeah did
you say 10 what was the number
on what
you said
i didn't say percentage i just said
national guard new york new york may use
national can you pull up the story from
the guardian i just want to read this
whole story here
uh the hoco hoco is the last name hocal
h-o-c-h-u-l-c so uh new york may use
national guard to replace guys if we can
flip the camera on the back end thank
you replace uh unvaccinated health
workers uh go a little lower go a little
lower the governor of new york cathy is
considering his national guard out of
state medical workers to
fill hospital staffing shortages as tens
of thousands workers are unlikely to
meet a monday deadline for mandated cova
19 vaccinations the plan outlined a
statement would allow the governor to
declare state of emergency and thereby
increase the supply of healthcare
workers to include licensed
professionals from other states and
countries as well as retired nurses
hocus stay said the state was also
looking at nash using national guard
officers with medical okay got it to
keep hospitals and other medical
facilities adequately staffed some 16
percent of the state's 450 000 hospital
staff or roughly 70 000 workers have not
yet been fully vaccinated the governor's
office so 16 of the
70 000 out of 450 000 hospital staff has
not yet been vaccinated we are still in
battle against cover to protect our
loved ones i commend all the health care
workers who have stepped up to get
themselves vaccinated i urge all the
remaining health care workers who are
unvaccinated to do so now so they can
continue providing care the plan comes
amid a broader battle between the state
and federal government leaders pushing
for vaccine mandates to help counter the
highly infectious delta variant of the
coronavirus and workers who are against
inoculation requirements some on
religious grounds on sunday hokule
attended somerset
church service to ask christians to help
promote vaccines i need you to
be my apostles wow okay great
i need you to go out and talk about it
and say we owe this to each other and
she said this to congregants at
christian cultural center in brooklyn
jesus taught us to love one another and
how do you show that love but to care
about each other enough to say please
get the vaccine because i love you and i
want you to live
healthcare workers how do you process
that last point as a christian as a
believer when someone uses the jesus
would want this go get vaccinated no you
have to know that that argument was the
worst argument to make because
god gives everybody what free will right
what's free will
you choose what you want to do and most
of the problems that we have in our
lives it's self-inflicted we don't you
know if you think about most your
problems you had in your life it's not
from the outset it's probably from the
inside decisions we made
things that we did so for you to say
you know jeez use jesus card to get me
to say hey listen son i love you so much
but you better get your ass vaccinated
or else like there's a little bit of
that yeah i find it very funny
here's here's what i will tell you in
regards to this there's no question the
delta varian is probably stronger
than the kovit that came just from the
stories that i'm hearing about and
this is not one case two case five cases
ten cases i'm talking hundreds of cases
of people that i'm in communication with
that they're going through it i had
covet you had covet wasn't pretty okay
we didn't enjoy it we went and got
tested on the same day you came out
negative i came positive and i still had
to go was i lost how much weight did you
see me lose when i went i would say 15
20 pounds you were you didn't recognize
me when you saw me i recognized you i
was like you gotta go eat a sandwich
you're gonna i can't keep nothing i
can't eat anything yeah i couldn't eat
anything right so then the delta comes
up yeah
and i told you a story about my dad
right and my uh uh uh
melva both being vaccinated he's 79 he
had covenant had pneumonia i don't know
what would have had him if he wouldn't
have had the
yeah the vaccination so it likely helped
him
i'm telling you right now i'm in my
skeptic side from odds i'm saying 80
chance it helped him i'm saying that so
thank god you know he's still here right
now for the doctors
uh who were uh pushed and challenged by
the president to come up with the
vaccine three days after the election
was over with that they finally came up
and nobody thought this was going to
come out in 18 months more power to him
for them to come out and bring that
option out there for people
but the fourth part man the biggest
thing is the fourth part buddy it's the
biggest thing you know
you know when i chose to be in the
military the choice you make when you
join the army you are government
property that's what you are when you
join the army the government owns you gi
joe government-issued joe government
owns you literally the government owns
your body for the contract you told the
story on rogan where you went in
11 shots and by the way did you see how
many people commented on the bottom of
what they said people were messaging me
saying the fact that yep that's ex he
says the people said if you were in the
military you know exactly what pat is
talking about because we all went
through it it's a line you just go
through there's no questions no you
can't ask nothing what's the side
effects of this oh shut up
you're just kind of going through that
particular reason i'm part of the reason
why you do not like mandates because you
were mandated as a part of the military
this is what you have to do follow
orders you're like look i'm free now i'm
good dude we're in america because it's
free what are we talking about what the
benefit america offers the benefit
america offers is for you to choose
steve america
what america offers so you know i don't
know i think uh
i think there if the 97 percent three
percent that is proof
to get to 97 percent which stories seven
percent it's impossible
that's what biden said what is it one of
these stories no i don't think so can
you ever
which is pretty good i think vaccine 97
kai just put by night holy [ __ ] this
guy's writing a novel just type in
there you go freaking kai buddy back to
buy them wants 97 percent of the country
to be
vaccinated uh okay eurozone reunites are
pretty good looking uh here we go
reporter how many americans need to be
vaccinated to get us back to normal by
97 98 i think we'll get awful awfully
close but i'm not the scientist i think
one thing is for certain a quarter of
the country can't
go unvaccinated and us not continue to
have a problem well his math is
way off bro 97 to 98 percent that's uh
yeah how does he even think that's
realistic
like he can't even well you set the bar
so high it's insane well they're also
going to stay
they're doing crazy stuff they're making
experimental rna vaccines that are going
into lettuce and other other food
products where they're going to put the
vaccine well luckily you're not eating
any of that so you're good
they sneak lettuce onto a cheeseburger
every now and then they might still get
me let me tell you bro take it off gene
go going back up with that what what
hulkel said man when she brought jesus
into it i mean that's that is such a
grimy political move it's also somebody
that's never read the bible like even
once jesus died fighting the hierarchy
yeah he fought the hierarchy flipped
over the tables of the jews who
went in and made deals with the romans
jesus was it was a political rebel so
for her to be like
i'm sorry guys
jesus was a jew
of dude my people who jesus was
the point is guys the point is that that
you know for her to use jesus to be like
do what authority tells you to do when
it was literally the guy got he got
pinned
it sounds like she's desperate
to pull off some sort of agenda that she
has and she's incapable of rational
thinking when you go to churches and
you're not known for doing that on a
regular basis and then trying to plead
with them in the matter that she did
crazy can i can i ask adam for a second
seriously i mean you asked pat a
question
you need to prove your work man when you
ask pat what do you have against
mandates that's what dude what do you
have for mandates
what is it about mandates that you said
that i would throw a mandate nice try
gerrard
wait seriously if you're asking what
does he have against what i asked him i
said is that part of the reason because
the military forced him to take shots
nice try gerard fire let me ask you then
specifically no you're done you got shut
down you're done absolutely i don't give
a [ __ ] if it's your birthday you just
got shut down gerard
you shall wrestle you're right now
you're trying to try 100
questions you're trying to see you're
trying to get the questions
you're trying to use social
25 minutes to answer the question what
is it about mandates that you think are
okay i don't think they're okay that's
the whole point of my question that was
my whole point is that i don't think
mandates are okay nice try dude then
you're asking what the the fact that the
military right is somehow the reasoning
behind him saying no this to the i said
part of the reason you got to go back
and listen gerard okay yeah
so everybody everybody else that's okay
with the mandates okay let me let me ask
you that i see what you're trying to do
it's not gonna work good luck because
you gotta answer the question i already
said i'm not agreeing with mandates
should i speak satan
by the way
mandate
let me ask you this let me ask you this
let me ask you this so you guys can we
can go back and watch the rewind
afterwards but uh so so let's go back uh
and talk about
new york okay go back to new york and
i'm actually like literally think a guy
yesterday said what do you have so much
about new york you know people in real
estate this is i said you don't even
know how bad real estate is in new york
right now
you're paying a quarter of what the
price of a property's worth in new york
commercial or residential residential
bro you're buying a 40 million dollar
property for 10 million people are just
dumping [ __ ] right now in new york right
and no joke like this is actually not a
bad time if you want to capitalize of
stuff banking the fact that new york's
gonna come back to normal in the next
four to eight years it's not a bad time
to buy
you know some real penthouse type of
properties or prime location over there
it's not a bad time to make an
investment if you think new york's gonna
come back from but here's what i want
you to think about
imagine we're in new york right now so
imagine i decided to go move the podcast
and move the media company to greenwich
because we were talking about moving to
new york okay remember when the
conversation was of course greenwich was
at the top of the list and we're going
to go to great we're cool with your
decision but i want you to think about
this imagine
you fast forward to move one year
okay meeting we move to greenwich cove
it happens six months later actually go
there okay
so we moved to greenwich covet happened
six months later our office we set up is
in new york in manhattan shut down okay
so think about that and we're running
this podcast and you're walking the
streets of new york and you're coming to
podcast and you have to go through all
and then we want to go have lunch and we
want to go have dinner and we're the
casa de angelo we're going to whatever
the louis bossie play we're going
you want to do that and you're going
through the mandates that they're
offering how long until you say when the
hell are we leaving this place okay so
now imagine the people that are living
in new york who love new york who love
their mets their yankees their jets well
maybe not the jets they're they're
giants they're
you know they're whatever you call them
give me the swords rangers giants
islanders islanders all this stuff right
say all these guys they love these
sports teams and like you know what dude
i just can't do this anymore i gotta go
the the tipping point for the exodus for
california has just begun people thought
it happened when these guys left or
whatever five years ago no no no five
six years ago people left at 4c we were
seeing what was going to be taking place
the mass exodus in california is just
about to begin the max exodus in new
york is just about to begin the more
they push back on things like this guy
is going to be like i'm sorry i'm just
going to be moving out and it's not even
a republican's moving out or an
independence moving out or a
libertarian's moving out i'm just i just
want to be free i'm just leaving i'm
going to go do my own thing here and i'm
going to choose a different state they
haven't even gotten a flavor of it but
here's the here's a question you got to
ask yourself
think about
the people at the top of the democratic
party okay
who's at the top of the democratic party
today i'm not talking obama's the face
i'm talking at the top
pelosi
schumer
i put i pelosi feinstein is very very
important einstein let's say those guys
but let's just say pelosi at the top do
you think kathy is somebody she likes
more than cuomo who do you think she
likes more i think she likes kathy i
think she likes cat yeah because kathy's
doing what they're standing for same as
california news and all that other stuff
they're going in that direction
everything like even michael bury i got
a bunch of stuff i want to talk about
with michael berry okay can you pull up
michael bury's article from yesterday or
today today is today the 27th or the
20th 28th yesterday berry comes out with
an article uh he said a few things so
this is a business insider story
yesterday the big short investor michael
berry warns the stock market boom
reminds him of the dot-com bubble and
rings the alarm on options mania okay go
to the bottom he uh uh uh burri said the
current market boom reminds me of
frenzy rampant speculation that uh uh
persephone
precipitated the great depression flurry
of a recent tweet that has since been
deleted he does that quite often by the
way the scion asset management by the
way which since 2015 has given returns
of 26
is what his management uh
uh asset management company has done
tweeted a screenshot of financial
web.com stock chart the defunct
the defunct company behind stock
detective and other financial
information websites saw its share
prices uh uh take a nosedive from a high
of 28 dollars to a fraction of a cent
following the dot-com crash a very
common chart back in the day berry said
looks vaguely familiar moreover the
hedge fund manager compared the bull
market during the 15 years of 2000 to
the run up in the stocks over the last
15 years he highlighted 94 correlation
between the nasdaq 100s performance in
each of the periods and a 95 correlation
for the s p 500 index so he continues he
continues to compare to 1929 what's
going to be happening et cetera et
cetera now watch this
so i kind of looked at some of his
positions and what he has here's his
positions
put options are investments what he
thinks is going to go down call options
is stuff that he thinks is going to be
going up okay
put options he has 700 and
730 million dollars of tesla stock 730
million
it's gonna go down okay put is what he's
got
he's got 280 million dollars of shares
of 20 or plus treasury bond okay etfs
it's called tlt okay on puts on puts
that's going to go down he's got call
options that's right you ready that's
really bad for the contractor of course
it is but watch what he has call options
on even though if you go to his twitter
a profile go to his twitter profile that
says michael j bury and it's like
cassandra or something like that very
weird with his twitter profile let's go
type in michael jaybury
uh michael j bury
uh right there cassandra well steve
carell that's roles look what hashtag
he's got wrestling peter uh rest in
peace alexi you know what he's talking
about rest in peace petrov boycott
amazon boycott facebook boycott coke
that's his hashtag in his account right
and we'll read the article he has down
here as well
you know what he's got for his call
options
and he just increased the amount of uh
money he put into this 70 quarter over
prior quarter highest money he's got of
a company that he thinks is gonna go up
facebook
327 million dollars of call options
230 million dollars of google he
increased that by 14 quarter of a
quarter but increased facebook 71
percent quarter of a quarter he's got
130 million in mckesson 58 million heinz
ketchup like heinz like kraft heinz
53 million in walmart 48 million in
cardinal health 43 million in cvs 9
million of a fund that short treasury
bonds let me say that one more time
that's short on treasury bonds and this
is based on three different things as
he's looking at number one inflation
inflation is not going to affect any of
the stuff that he has for call options
with facebook google mckesson heinz
walmart cbs he says inflation's not
going to affect those guys at all
inflation would affect tesla treasury
bonds else et cetera so number one is
inflation it's coming number two is
interest rates are going to go up it's
coming number three bond yields will
increase which means bond prices
will decrease and he is so certain that
this is gonna be taking place that he's
putting his money where his mouth is and
he's predicting big short two is around
the corner this guy's not a dummy
he doesn't say things like this he's not
a guy that's just getting up there and
saying let me like harry dent wrote a
book remember harry dent that said i
don't know if you guys remember harry
dent's old book that he was saying the
it's going to be the biggest market boom
ever the dow jones going to go to 43 000
by 1999. i don't know the exact date can
you put a harry dent
uh prediction
you're talking about michael j bury that
a movie was written about and he did
something where everybody thought he was
an idiot
and everybody ended up calling him a
hero because the major prediction that
he made so if this is the case and he's
talking about a uh uh where's his old
book the great he has an old book the
next great bubble the roaring two boom
the rory yeah he's made uh
yeah he's he's uh he's talked about
where the market's going to go he's
called the next crash and a lot of stuff
but he wrote books where made a lot of
sense and then the opposite of what
happened this is not him this is michael
j berry okay he's got 730 million
dollars of tesla stock he's shorting
it's not a small amount why tesla of all
things well
maybe the global shipping crisis has a
factor in that two chips chips shipping
crisis
you know a he's never been able to meet
his deadlines with cars
when inflation goes up people are not
going to have to money to go out there
and just buy stuff like that he's also
been against tesla in in terms of their
market cap versus their output of cars
for a long time so this isn't anything
new he's saying with tesla's overpriced
with the whole uh sledgehammer to
souffle kind of analogy so he's been
talking about personality for the last
year yeah and how could you not think
that elon could get a little distracted
with everything else he has how much can
he really put into
tesla that's necessary how long is the
put and how long are the call options do
you know does he say does he give a
duration you can probably go up there
and find the timeline to see what's
going on but but the point is
when a guy like this talks you have to
pay very close attention by the way this
leads to the next thing
with crypto and by the way he's
predicting crypto's also going to take a
massive hit he's not saying
cryptocurrency says crypto's on the list
of getting their asses handed to them
because you saw what happened with china
right china declares all cryptocurrency
transactions illegal you saw bitcoin
took a hit ethereum took a hit everybody
took a hit
uh with that so uh a china central bank
has announced that all transactions of
cryptocurrencies are illegal effectively
banning digital tokens such as bitcoin
fluctuations there
often impact the global price of
cryptocurrencies and the price of
bitcoin fell by more than two thousand
dollars in a week of chinese
announcements it is the latest in
china's national crackdown on what is
what it sees as a volatile speculative
investment at best and a way to launder
money at worst trading
cryptocurrencies has officially been
banned in china since 2019 but as
continued online foreign exchanges but
last week's announcement is the clearest
indication yet that china wants to shut
down cryptocurrencies trading in all its
forms is what they want to do so
barry is uh
barry's not a double he's got a track
record and if people thought he was
crazy when he said that the housing
market was going to crash i think when
you have that much credibility and you
just look at the evidence when you look
at inflation you look at the situation
in china with evergrande the debt
ceiling inflation global shipping
shortage i mean there's just so many
things that are stacked up against the
stock market continuing to boom
and china at the same time they're
showing their cards they're also kind of
telling the world look you know here's
the direction we're going if you
there was a girl that was a star social
media star with like 40 50 million
followers overnight she disappeared like
what the hell happened to her like a
huge star the guy that was worth 38
billion dollars overnight his 38 billion
is gone jack ma says one thing in front
of uh
you know talking against china hey
when's the last time you saw jack ma
doing an interview with cnbc or msnbc or
anything that was a year ago and that
was a year ago we talked about on rogan
about capitalism and communism and about
lifting up individuals but also like the
team the collective and that's kind of
what china's doing is they don't want
superstars they don't want superstars
yeah and this is shining a spotlight on
basically what china wants they want to
um they want control they want to you
know have regulation all over crypto but
something that we're not talking about
is because they're banning crypto and
banning bitcoin part of the reason is
they want to develop their own digital
juan and and do all that so they
they you know we talked about the social
score on rogan you talked about that
china is basically trying to control
your whole life and they don't want
superstars that's why the people like
jack ma
you know yeah they go to re-education
camps well we we talked about it on the
last podcast guys that um you know
where's the epicenter of power in
america it used to be new york he used
to be dc maybe la it's it's all san
francisco now all tech right we talked
about it and he's betting against
america not once twice he's saying
treasury bonds are going down that's
betting against america you're betting
the country is is about to be in big bad
shape but you're betting on facebook and
google so if america is going down but
tech is going up i think that that kind
of tells you where where the power
within tech really lies and we we talk
not to get too crazy with it guys but i
mean if anybody out there wants to spend
the rest of their day going down a fun
rabbit hole check out the frankfurt
school check out what critical theory is
we hear a lot about critical race theory
today critical race theory is the latest
incarnation of something called critical
theory critical theory was a way that
hegelians and marxists decided that they
would try to implement communism in
society and basically you have to break
the wheel in order in order to implement
a communist revolution or a worldwide
communist revolution i'm not saying this
is what's happening i'm just saying if
you want to do some fun reading okay
antonio gramsci who the president of
ireland just stopped and paid respects
to at his grave
this guy's not a good man here
you know antonio gramsci not a good man
i don't know what kind of a man he was
his philosophy is very dangerous so in
order to bring in a global communist
revolution you have to break the wheel
all right in times of prosperity nobody
wants revolution
so in order for them if you believe in
in buildback better if you believe in a
future where you will own nothing and be
happy
in order for that to happen a crash is
is is absolutely necessary and they talk
about it at length at the frankfurt
school they talk about cultural hegemony
this is guys if if you've studied kind
of you know political theory if you've
if you've studied this stuff a lot of
this is like you're seeing a slow-motion
train wreck
it's it's kind of nuts but just enjoy
check out the frankfurt school i think
you guys will get some value and some
payment out of that even if there is
this crash
that there's a crash so how many crashes
have we experienced time
so it's not a time let's say 10.com boom
i'm saying in the last 20 years dot com
boom lasted a year or so 2008 lasted a
couple years
20 i mean covet lasted like six months
as far as the the market goes
so
it's going to crash it's a crash the
housing crash the market crash
if you're young and you're in the stock
market and you have crypto is are you
really that worried there's one more
older people did i tell you one thing
concerns me here's what concerns me i
agree you know how it's like
it's cyclical it happens it's cyclical
it happens this is no different it's
cyclical it happens this is no different
it's cyclical it happens right okay fine
let's say it is only cyclical and it
happens there's one thing that's not
normal
um
40 plus percent of the currency was
printed last 18 months right that's a
lot of money was sent free to people bro
we've not sent like money like that to
people we're just people are sitting on
the sidelines saying no if you pay me
this i'll come and companies like [ __ ]
this guy's only worth 18 bucks an hour
at best i have to pay this guy 28 bucks
to come back to work what the hell do i
do okay i'll give you 28 bucks and okay
and you better not let me go out 458 and
then it's like a very weird dynamic
that's going on today right like
employers are begging and this is what
they want employers are begging people
to come back to work and people say no
i'm good man i'm playing video games i'm
chilling playing netflix so how long
when that goes do you get the person
want to come back and really give their
best i don't know so that's one thing
that leads to fake success now they're
talking another three and a half
trillion dollars
which i don't know if you've looked at
what's in the three and a half trillion
dollars again a bunch of other [ __ ]
that they've added to the three and a
half three and a half trillion dollars
well the senate just struck it down and
you saw what biden just said you know
what biden just said with the money when
no americans are not going to pay for it
this is not going to go to the death
effort
this is not going to go to our deficit
will not pay anything for it it's going
to pay for itself pelosi is saying it's
going to pay for itself it's going to
pay for its sales job right and you know
what she said again here's what she said
look let's just pass it so we can find
out what's in it same line she's used
in the past before
this is not a new thing that these guys
are doing so are you saying that and i
gave you three examples 2001 2008 2020
that this potential crash would be worse
one go to each one yeah what is a one oh
one was just you know
dot com boom i bought no no oh one oh
one what you're talking about nine
eleven or one talking about no well it
was 99 yeah 99 2000 2001 all that free
money yeah private equity got into the
game okay and they started putting money
to people that really didn't have the
best idea and it was just like it
flapped just as long as that calm behind
it and then
that was the market and then obviously
911. so it was a lot of fake money there
but it was created by who
the market created fake money okay in
98.99 the more we're evaluating
companies that's right the market so
that's cool the market creates fake
success guess what you're going to take
ahead you're going to lose billions and
you're going to have to come back and
treat it in different ways that's a
correction go to osa that's a correction
go to o7 what was what was the deal with
07. housing housing a program comes from
australia called no income no ass it's
nina okay where it's a pick a payment
and everybody's buying a
million dollar house michael murray
everything that's right and the big
short and then what happens there fake
success
more fake success who takes a hit a 330
billion dollar company called wamu gets
bought by a chase for 1.9 billion
dollars
there were some victims bear stearns had
to go down sure um but who else okay
well that's a lot there's a lot a lot of
victims i mean country-wide you forget
countrywide was like all over the place
fremont invested it's a lot of big
mortgages so but then you go to today
so you said 0-1 right 008 today today
2020 exactly well 2020 is a cobia
because if kobe doesn't hit trump's
getting re-elected the economy was doing
great people were working people were
talking about the median income had
increased for the first time in 20 years
it had increased to 60 000 from 55 000
under his watch unemployment for
everybody was fine
record low blacks hispanics women in
every way everything was good china was
having to kind of change back and kind
of see what they're going to do with u.s
you know isis you didn't hear a single
thing about isis all that stuff sweets
pat but but but i will tell you though
there's a part of that that he he is his
own enemy there's there's nobody that's
a bigger enemy than himself on what he
did but his his policies very effective
policies benkovic shows up and kobe
becomes a great opportunity to do what
impose any ideas that you want we could
have been united and the enemy would
have been china but no instead of
creating the enemy because like right
now let's just say uh uh let's just say
something happens in this building okay
and the building uh is on fire okay
when a building's on fire there's a
couple things the building could do like
remember that one day the car was on
fire everybody's running i'm on a board
call they're telling me pat you got to
go downstairs all this other stuff i
don't remember this it was like four
weeks ago oh yeah okay told me not to
come in that day
so guess what happened well they tell
you not to come in every day
just keep showing up and you still show
up
they've resorted to starting cars but
watch what happens that day
what happened that day when they told us
it's a fire do you actually remember no
we're going oh you weren't here so we
ran downstairs we're holding doors for
each other come on folks let's go come
on let's go too because the enemy was
what the fire right makes sense now
imagine if somebody said
he did it it's his fault this guy did it
he's doing it it's because of him and
we're like who him hi it's cassio
so so the point is
rather than using covet to unify america
the left saw this and say perfect
opportunity to make trump the villain
ding ding ding ding ding you win he's
out but the reality was china caused the
great divorce
china is the one that caused the fire
that's the challenge that we have and
now fast forward to today you give all
this money to people for a while
and you get employers to go against
employ everything right now is against
against employers against employees
men against women parents against kids
okay republicans against democrats
against citizens policing versus
patience whites against black versus
whites against blacks a church going
against and
everything is against adam versus gerard
let's go you know
it is my birthday that constant against
is what's causing us to be yeah and it's
becoming the new normal which is what's
which is what they want and which is
really really so this is a very
different thing adam asked that question
i don't know how does that affect the
economy though but like all that makes
sense but
what is that going to actually do for
this crash we this whole thing started
with michael bury's pred predicting this
crash dude another big short puts calls
yeah i just told you 40 percent of the
money what's printed that's what's
what's the prediction of what will
happen inflation it's impossible to
protect because this isn't a market okay
okay let me let me read this let me read
over here let me read this to you costco
nike and fedex are warning there's more
inflation said to it consumers that
holiday approaches the nbc story well
costco nike and fedex are not
politicians they're not democrats or
republicans costco has joined a long
list of retailers sounding the alarm
about escalating shipping prices and
accompanying supply chain issues the
warehouse retailer was joined by
athletic where giant nike and economic
belt weathers uh uh fedex and general
mills in discussing similar concerns the
cost to ship containers overseas has
soared in recent months getting a
40-foot container from shanghai to new
york cost two thousand dollars a year
and a half ago before covet you know
what it is right now sixteen thousand
dollars let me say this one more time
yeah so costco nike and fedex saying
guys i'm sorry we have to raise our
prices people like what do you know
you're not gonna raise your prices no no
i don't think you understand these
containers when we get our stuff from
shanghai used to cost only two grand
we're paying eight times more today
16 grand a pop the cost includes not
only freight but also higher labor costs
rising demand for transportation and
products plus shortages and computer
chips oils chemicals and higher
commodity prices we can't we can't hold
on to all of those
some of that has to be passed on to who
to us
and it is being passed on we're
pragmatic about it said costco cfo reach
richard gallanty so
basic mathematics here you just saw
what's going on so you're asking the
question pat what is this what is this
so different bro it's not a little bit
of inflation if something increased from
two million to
you know if something can increase from
10 bucks to 12 bucks what do you say
whatever if something you're buying
normally goes from 10 bucks to 15 bucks
what do you say dude that's a little
weird wouldn't you say that like think
about what you buy every month imagine
if the gym membership's 50 bucks a month
do you complain no imagine next 124 hour
fitness says it's gonna be 75 bucks next
month now let me give you a different
one imagine 24 hour fitness all of a
sudden says
we know your membership's been 50 a
month for the last 10 years effective
next month is 400 bucks a month
that's just what happened to these guys
how sustainable is that
what do you where else do you get it
from
and china guess what china's going to
say don't get it from us
don't go elsewhere where do you go well
as a consumer we have the option to say
well sorry uh no you don't know
i'm not getting it but you don't have to
you don't have you're not gonna have the
option do you know why you're not gonna
have the option here's why you're not
going to have the option okay put two
things that we can com companies that
compete against each other mcdonald's
burger king mm-hmm go uh starbucks uh
what's the other one uh
coffee bean okay i would put mcdonald's
versus dunkin donuts because the
coffee's about the same price right okay
so
say i'm toyota say i'm ford your gm
and i say
oh man dude these just we gotta freaking
do something you know let's raise the
price of 30
you're for it what do you say
we're going to stake to the same prices
okay cool do it
one month goes by two months goes by
three months two quarters three quarters
your cfo comes in
uh remember how you wanted to report
your earnings and you wanted ebitda to
be higher we have depleted our cash this
much in the last three quarters you sure
you don't want to raise the prices
oh then the boy you have a board meeting
uh ceo of ford listen we're looking at
the numbers and the profits in the last
three quarters and we haven't risen
prices but gm has and chrysler has
what are we going to do to raise prices
to match our competitors and you're the
ceo what do you say i don't think it's
fair are you kidding me the ceo's going
to say
okay
all right so the regular ford focus that
was twenty two thousand dollars is now
twenty nine thousand dollars who feels
it
so there is you you don't have the
choice anymore adam
that you don't have another alternative
it's the illusion i try to look at it
from a consumer's perspective hear me
out yeah okay other than saving your
money or investing and having a better
asset allocation plan yeah what the hell
are you going to do about it nothing
it is what it is what do you mean no no
what do you mean you as a consumer if
inflation is
wisely what else are you gonna do
really bro okay so uh how many people go
to costco
millions how many people ship stuff
how many people use fedex how many
people should there's a lot a lot okay
you don't have a choice but have that
being felt that's my point it's like all
right it is what it is i have no say
over this inflation of course you don't
have sex exactly what's your point
though that's my point is that it is
what it is nobody other than being smart
with your own money it works because you
know what comes what i mean it is what
it is bro you know what comes next
the dollar gets weaker it's still the
strongest currency in the world the
dollar gets weaker the economy takes a
hit
people are out there not knowing how to
make an income more division amongst
everybody then you have more protesting
then you have more rights then what the
hell do you do
this is what comes next this is not
sustainable to go like this
you cannot have fake success for too
long bro listen name any bodybuilder
there was a guy on youtube that was had
a youtube channel million and a half
subscribe i don't remember his name but
pena piana piano some name like that and
he was everywhere and he said for 20
years i've been straight on steroids and
growth hormone
for 20 years he said that for 20 years
and he did a video he says my hand used
to be this big now it's this big i used
to be size 11 shoes now i'm 13 and a
half my hat used to be seven now it's
eight and a half whatever he
tells you exactly my heart used to be
this size he's this size you know what
happened to him three years ago four
years ago what do you think happened to
him
guy passed away
cool looking guy spoke very well was
very eloquent passed away
you cannot have fake testosterone for
your entire life and you're overdosing
on it
america's had fake steroids growth
hormone for uh
how many how long have we been at zero
interest rate at the number that we're
less than one percent
america's been on steroids and growth
hormone for so long that the moment you
get off of it when you get off the
stairs your skin gets yellow because
your body forgot how to produce
testosterone when america gets off of
this all growth hormone and steroids
america's economy is not going to know
how to reproduce it it's going to take a
while this is not like a
another 001 or 08 no we're not talking
about another 0108 this is catastrophic
let me and the fact that michael bury
has the audacity to go out and talk
about the stuff more freaking power to
him it's forcing us to have the
conversation it's
for somebody to actually make you
question
that inflation is not there no no no no
no and powell
you you're not talking about lightweight
people yelling
people like that that are saying no this
is normal notice what the hell do you
mean this is normal it's not normal
lying through the teeth
but but but it's not i don't think it's
the
lying through the
teeth because i think that's not a
republican democrat thing i think
everybody's lying through their teeth i
think it's more the following i think
here's what it is okay
i think it's more from the standpoint of
i look at it yeah i think the person
i think it's from the standpoint of the
following thing
do your parents lie to you
yeah for how long
let me ask you a question my whole life
for your own good is it good that your
parents lie to you
think about the question right there
it tends what they're lying about white
lies whatever i don't know let me ask
you a question you're four years old
mommy how are babies or babies or babies
are born is it good for your mom to tell
you exactly how babies are born probably
not at that probably not they're lying
to you though right parents
do you think it's good to say uh santa
claus is fake at three years old to a
kid no
but you're lying yeah parents are liars
okay fine
but you lied to me at three fine true
four
fine
if you're lying to me at 38 right what
the hell are we doing
i understand yelling lion i understand
there's a part of it but dude this is no
longer a time to lie you have to come up
and say we have an issue america here's
what we need to start doing save the
freaking money
kick back a little bit okay chill out
with the spending habits let's kind of
change some of these habits that we have
no more talking to american adults as if
they're four-year-olds you're scared
shitless whether they're gonna believe
in santa claus anymore tell them the
damn truth i'm 40 years old santa
doesn't exist
tell me he doesn't exist tell me some of
these things here it's time for me to
know and these guys are treating adults
as if they're kids no inflation is gonna
hit us
this is not something that's fake this
is not something that's just the
rhetoric they're lying because they
think they're protecting us right and
that's their that's their whole motive
and what's gonna happen when all these
things all these things do happen the
global shipping crisis you're gonna
watch the christmas shopping this year
wait till you see what you're not being
able to get wait till you see how much
your nike shoes are getting jacked up
this is all real i'll tell you another
thing um i can see
any day six of these huge
tankers or these huge vessels that carry
all the goods from china i can see them
every day from my deck with binoculars
they're out there i don't know if
they're coming in and they can't get in
or if they've unloaded in their head and
back i've never seen it before but if
you look at these aerial images of long
beach or even in new york there's 80
ships waiting a month to unload all this
stuff is going to happen so when you and
then they think they could just put a
band-aid on it with 3.5 trillion dollars
and just keep paying money but who are
we going to blame when this all does all
the [ __ ] does hit the fan with inflation
with you're going to the grocery store
and things aren't there and and you
can't order things on amazon that you're
used to will they blame the democrats
and if and if it coincides with a market
crash will that
mitch would that be the impetus to get
people out mitch mcconnell is just as
much at fault for this than as any
democrat number one number two i think
the big difference here guys and you
both made really really good points the
big difference is here your parents lie
to you because they love you
you know they want to protect you
these politicians are lying to us
because they think we're stupid and they
want to protect themselves they want to
protect they want to protect their jobs
and they want to protect their their
their q score they want to protect their
chance at reelection are your parents
live for your own good politicians lie
for their own good and that's something
that needs to be understood
democracy democrats
when you were talking about the fact
that this is kind of like an engineered
crisis they're not hiding that this is
from march of last year this is the
majority whip the house majority whip
the number two democrat in the entire
congress okay uh tim clybourn this is
when kovid was raging everything was
just getting shut down we had no idea we
thought that this was the black plague
still okay new york was completely empty
his response is the coronavirus is a
tremendous opportunity to restructure
things to fit our vision
this has been played out guys for 18
months
this is not new as soon as this thing
happened all right as soon as this thing
happened people in power saw this and
said okay
open the piggy bank let's get our let's
do you want the green new deal here it
is what do you need who are our donors
let's get it to them right here and they
didn't lie about it this was one of the
times where they said the quiet part out
loud the coronavirus is a chance to fit
this one i mean i don't know i get that
and by the way listen
both sides are opportunistic and what
they're doing both sides are
opportunistic you have to know but one
side is wanting to put the mo more the
onus on you the other side wants to
put the onus on rich people so one is
saying look you can do something about
your life the other side is saying no
poor you you can't do anything about
your life you're a victim let us help
save you right one is trying to be your
hero the other one's trying to say why
don't you do something about yourself
because when you win you feel better
about yourself when you accomplish
something you feel good about yourself
what happened when you won a game you
felt good about yourself what happened
when you got that job and you got a
promotion you felt good about yourself
what happened when you got you know
first ten thousand dollars in a bank you
felt good about yourself what happened
when you bought your first car without
needing mommy and daddy you felt good
about yourself this is all confidence
boosting opportunities right that we
have
one side's saying no you don't
understand you are a victim
you you're not as smart as them we we
know what we're doing we know what's
best for you the other side is saying i
believe in you i think you're capable
once you go do something about it let's
go and and i think you can pull this off
let's see what you got how bad you want
it it's a different level of coaching on
what you got it
so i'm not surprised that this is taking
place all i'm saying is when it comes
down to the numbers right now what we're
talking about adam this is not the same
thing here but when was this the speech
that he gave march 2022.
march 2020 23rd yeah okay
so trump was still president republicans
still controlled the senate at that
point yeah trump you know one thing that
i love about republicans is they'll talk
about you know not spending as much
lowering the deficit balancing the
budget and then they don't [ __ ] do it
like trump spent as much money and
yeah with stimulus as any democrat ever
so
rhetoric is one way stop stops rhetoric
is one thing and then what they actually
do is another stop who has to pass it
who has to pass the stimulus house okay
and control and the president has
assignments who control them who control
the house
democrats had the house republicans had
the senate and trump was president at
the time of this door so what does he do
at a point like that
the point listen this isn't a debate he
passed it no no no but it's not about he
passed it do you remember how they
create a climate for it to be passed so
fine now go there do you think at the
time when you passed it it was necessary
the hell the hostage now i'm asking you
do you think at the time it was
necessary to pass it
in hindsight yes yeah okay do you think
it's necessary today to do three and a
half trillion dollar bill i don't know
it just seems like a lot of printing of
the money like to your point okay so so
it's a slippery slope so but
you're basically trying to say like i
don't know what your intention was
but at the time of this speech that
reinvent the wheel when i get the
podcast did we support it
did we do the podcast in march of 20 we
started when we were talking about it
did we support it
do we support it i think it was we had
an open forum debate about it yeah we
like hey let's go out there and spend
all the money was i for printing money
now no not at all am i a guy that's
saying let's keep printing money and
keep give money away to people no no but
if you
shut me down and i'm california and i
can't get out you don't have the right
to shut me down without paying me yeah
do you understand like hey you can't
come to work i'm sorry bro what do you
want me to do
i have to take care of my family at
least pay me we have to pay you you
can't do one without the other
because if you do and if they don't pay
remember with the conversation we had
with they said if they don't pass this
year what do you think is going to
happen in the streets people going to
find a way to get their money how to get
them get their money remember there was
like a three-month period where people
were worried on the streets what's going
to be happening you remember the crime
was up breaking into houses do you
forget those stories so you can't
corner one side and put people in their
houses and tell them you can't get out
and not have to make that move that's
not the case today but today they want
to do more than they did a year a year
ago my point is this do democrats not
know how to balance budget the last time
we had a balanced budget was under bill
clinton let's not forget that yeah the
last time we had a balanced budget dude
okay what sure what part
what part of this conversation is left
or right what part of this conversation
is left to right i think gerrard's point
was that it was a large point was a
difference that's my point my point on
this was that this isn't a market
correction that we're hearing this isn't
a market correction that we're living
through my whole point of bringing this
up isn't democrat republican it's the
fact that this isn't a market correction
against you know uh uh free money in the
marketplace or or a derivative problem
this is a government-created problem all
right let's change it up here caroline
can you please bring the bottle of water
for me please
uh uh
okay all right let's do this it's
gerard's birthday
so we have to sink for him and we got
him a cake nice all right if you guys
ready on three let's do it on three one
two three happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear gerard
happy birthday
to you what's your wish tell us oh i
want world peace
happy birthday i'll kill you i want
world peace even if i have to get it by
force we should have had this at the
beginning of the show get a little uh
sugar rush thank you guys so much man
thank you caroline thank you guys you're
welcome jar just venmo us when you can
yeah
hey and if you need me what'd you say
venmo just vetoes when you get it
can i get a fan to blow out the candles
or something like that i don't know how
this goes in today's world
very politically correct anyways gang
we're gonna do it again on thursday uh
go give gerard some love put his
instagram account down in the comment
section kai so people can go give him
love and give him a follow uh good
conversation today good commentary tom
glad to have you thanks for having me
take care guys we'll see you again on
thursday take care bye bye bye bye
you